hey everyone I'm a be sharp and I'ma be
later
we are both opinionated dieticians and
we gonna be fun to take apart a few of
the most outrageous diets we've seen out
there there's a lot about a lot of ones
yeah it's like actually like eating
paper towel tities powder it's health
does but the reality is I think people
actually think this is gonna work
because be honest it may work because
you're cutting out so many important
healthy great foods but you just be so
miserable why what's the point of eating
yeah the couch is like yeah I think
there's a difference we prosecute an
ulcer process they talk about that all
the time
so ultra-processed obviously it's great
to limit those but process like we've
gained a lot of game a lot of benefits
from some of the technology over the
past few years as a ship knows and
important it kind of prevents a lot of
diseases this serious it's something we
want to prevent yeah we both know this
one addy and I both written about the
butter coffee excuse it's frothy and
delicious so really obviously this is
just a marketing plug to sell more of a
specific kind of coffee the guy who
invented it has not one iota of
scientific or nutrition background at
all yeah people say they they feel
really cool but the butter the coffee
has 600 hours yeah obviously gonna feel
full that's quite a breakfast like well
I just take a chunk of crystals
yeah
no my mother oh no no I'll say can't
talk some sense of or let's be honest we
have like our own pH balancing
mechanisms if we didn't we would die we
would die from eating it or in any other
day a can of coke on your Nelly you know
I think it's also because people think
cancers rising in this acidic
environment by eating acidic foods then
it creates this cancer flourishing
environments that that's not where your
body works in soon no I think those
diets may t work because again they're
just restrictive and anything that's
restricted that's cutting out foods so
I'm a magic alkaline pill it's just like
hey you're eating fewer things so you
would like it's gonna suck more and
you're gonna eat less like yeah okay
okay no one on this diet ever ever the
Master Cleanse but what a bar I actually
went too far you got lemon juice maple
syrup up carb and cayenne pepper in
water and that's all you're gonna drink
this is the Master Cleanse it is the
granddaddy of all cleanses this is gonna
make me skinny it's gonna make me
clear-headed it's gonna make all my
bloating and inflammation go my brain
fog Oh broad brain fog what is that I
actually don't understand what brain fog
is
I don't feel foggy and I eat everything
yeah well thanks so much for watching
and thank you Abbi for joining me thank
you for having me and for more great
nutrition banter be sure to subscribe to
my channel and I'll see you next time on
happy citizens